what's a dark gentleman
ah so dark gentleman is a term i've
coined uh to reflect a man who has both
dark triad characteristics in some
capacity but is also benevolent so he's
not your you know psycho chad you know
uh narcissist
that wants to sleep with women but he
also incorporates the three ps that is
parental investment protection and
provision so it's this it's just what i
like to call a unity of contradiction so
combining
two things which are in logical contrast
but molding them together such that they
work in harmony
that's really interesting
so that's because there is a there is a
particular
degree of attraction that women have
toward dark triad traits why is that yes
yes those men are sexy right it's it's
the it's the um these characteristics
make people make these sorts of people
seem as though they're important right
there's that danger
that is often attributed to a man that
is that is uh psychopathic or
machiavellian and with narcissism it
makes perfect sense right a guy that
dresses well has
you know smiles uh
is very attractive in other words so he
he fulfills that chad component but a
man who is fully on the dark triad
spectrum doesn't necessarily fulfill the
dad perspective which women are also
looking for on a long-term perspective
so if you're actually combining the
short term which is the dark triad
aspect of it and the long term
perspective which is the the dad you
know
triple p perspective
you're getting the perfect guy in a
sense you're getting that unicorn
because you need an element or most men
with elements of dark triad traits are
more successful in short-term mating
opportunities but make bad term long bad
long-term mate prospects so getting
yourself uh
through the door so to speak um
with the dark triad traits and then
continuing and adding longevity to the
relationship with your three p's so the
chad and dad
yes precisely that so i was actually
having a conversation with jordan
peterson about this where he was saying
that
women want a man that is disagreeable
but also agreeable at the same time
because disagreeability is actually a
law of diminishing returns where you
know if a man is disagreeable in in uh
his workplace right he's probably going
to get an advance as we discuss in terms
of economics they typically make more
money but in a domestic setting a high
level of disagreeability doesn't work
very well so if your wife tells you hey
baby go take take out the trash and you
say no i don't want to do so i'm
disagreeable it's probably not going to
be conducive to a long and happy
marriage
but it's as with everything man you need
a balance
yes you don't want to be out
on the
top 10th percentile or bottom 10th
percentile of anything ever really
like i said i was sad i was um i tried
to justify uh
the number one
competitive advantage in the modern
world is to be 10 percent autistic over
a thanksgiving dinner
you just want you just want it's like
you know that the salt bay guy you just
want that much you want that much autism
and it's yeah yeah yeah precisely just a
smattering you know i think there's i
think there's probably some truth to
that because you want to have that sort
of gung-ho kind of [ __ ] you mentality
where you kind of just go off and do
your own thing yep and kind of just
throw caution to the wind but you kind
of have to dial it back
in since you can't go you can't i'm
going to use a
it's going to get me canceled if i use
it but it's sort of a traffic tropic
thunder thunder term i think the phrase
is go full [ __ ] as it were yep
that's fine i've used i've used i used
that i used that last week on the
podcast i don't know i'm talking about
jordan peterson i'm not famous not to
get canceled so okay uh so you've got a
quote here from the article we're
talking about a man who is too
ingratiating is ultimately a man who is
too desperate his inability to tell a
woman no is a direct reflection of his
over eagerness to please contrary to
popular belief telling a woman no in
specific circumstances is an attractive
quality as it signals that a man is not
a pilot doormat
yes yes you'd be surprised how
sexy saying no is to a woman because
you're sort of putting your foot down
you're taking a stand you're saying i'm
the man in the situation
and
a lot of women not all of them but you
know again we use the term on average
you're looking for leadership within a
relationship
and sometimes that requires saying no
and and taking the bull by the horns and
really taking the steering wheel and
also making decisions right
oh yeah oh yeah i mean look
if if you're in a relationship and
you're constantly stressed and you're
worried about life
would it not be better if you had
someone who was able to make decisions
in a cogent manner is able to lead lead
you along it's not to say that women are
incapable of making decisions or a man
is more capable of making decisions but
it's just it's just that less more or
less or less stressful when you have
someone there that is clear of thought
and care of mind and is able to make
decisions yeah i mean what would you say
to the people that say why why is that
the man's job why can't that be the
woman's job
well it can be either one of their jobs
right it sort of depends on the
relationship i'm not i i guess the point
i'm trying to get across here is that
it's not
different relationships work differently
for different people and so abiding by
the stereotypical notion that men should
always be the leader in a family i don't
think it's true if it doesn't work for
you and your partner so it may work it
may be the case that it works for most
people but some couples might find it
easier if the woman makes all the
decisions financially socially whatever
it is
you do need a polarity though having two
agreeable people or two disagreeable
people is a recipe for a [ __ ] always
you always need a a polarity between the
two it's a good point you've raised here
is that uh one one um
sort of guy that was writing on this
idea i forget what who he is and what
the book was but he said that for a good
relationship to work specifically when
it comes to to sex is that you need a
ravisher and a person that's ravished
ravished and the same thing applies here
in in in a relationship right you need
uh you need that that um
polarity right that unity of
contradictions what's happening people
if you enjoyed that then press here for
the full unedited episode and don't
forget to subscribe
peace